madame monsieur bonsoir j'ai été victime
d'un complot judiciaire ce sont les
premiers mots prononcés par bernard
bonnet à sa sortie de prison en fin
d'après midi à paris l'ancien préfet de
corse mises en examen dans la sphère des
paillotes a été remise en liberté après
avoir passé 60 jours en détention
ce soir il promet des révélations pierre
didier dans l'après midi
depuis ajaccio le juge cambérou avaient
signé lé ordonnance de remise en liberté
de l'ex préfet de corse à 17 heures dans
cette petite voiture
la fille et le fils de bernard bonnet
venus attendre leur père devant la santé
souriant mais amaigri il livre un
communiqué à la porte d'une prison où il
est resté détenu près de deux mois
j'affirme avoir été victime d'un complot
judiciaire ou pour être plus précis d'un
attentat judiciaire corse commis en
bande organisée
les auteurs de cet attentat ont volé
deux mois de ma vie je trouve
inacceptable qu'une ministre de la
république madame guigou puisse bafouer
avec une telle imprudence le principe de
la présomption d'innocence par les
déclarations qu'elle a faites au club de
la presse rock numéro un
je considère que de telles déclarations
sont une défaillance
à l'époque la garde des sceaux s'était
étonné que l'on s'insurge contre la mise
en détention provisoire de bernard
bonnet temps des jeunes sont également
placés en préventive pour des faits
moindre a piloté par son fils qui le
ramène vers un domicile parisien le
préfet hors-cadre semblait enfin se
détend sur la route une halte dans un
grand café parisien
toujours en compagnie de ses enfants
désormais placé sous contrôle judiciaire
assigné à résidence en ile de france il
est évidemment interdit à bernard bonnet
de rencontrer protagonistes ou témoins
de la sphère de la paillote garderaient
le silence pendant quelques jours et je
m'exprimerai à nouveau dans quelques
jours des mots lourds de sens
peu avant à la porte de la prison
bernard bonnet avait promis pour les
semaines qui viennent de nouveau coup de
théâtre